now that the remake for Resident Evil 4
is out one data Miner has uncovered
references to possible downloadable
content starring Leon Kennedy's favorite
friend of me have you completed the
Remake yet if so hit the comment section
and let me know if you're already hungry
for some more single player content for
the game this possible DLC was revealed
on Twitter by Resident Evil Central and
data Miner gosetsu apparently the
install files for the game contain a
folder titled the another order which
was the name of the extra game mode in
the Japanese version of the original
Resident Evil 4. this mode was renamed
separate ways when Resident Evil 4 was
translated to English and it focused on
what corporate spy Ada Wong was up to
during her brief appearances in the game
separate ways isn't included in the
Resident Evil 4 remake but the data
suggests that it could arrive in the
future for now plenty of other content
is coming to the new Resident Evil game
including mercenaries mode on April 7th
and a VR version of the game for
Playstation VR 2 which is now in the
early stages of development hopefully
that version comes with a less scary
mode in other news it looks like we'll
be getting a closer look at tiers of the
Kingdom gameplay this week Nintendo has
announced that it'll show roughly 10
minutes of gameplay from the breath of
the wild sequel on March 28th at 7 A.M
Pacific Time 10 a.m Eastern on the
company's official YouTube channel tears
of the kingdom is expected to be
Nintendo's biggest game release of 2023
and will be released on May 12th
exclusively for the switch so far
Nintendo has kept details on the game
mostly Under Wraps save for a rare
trailer occasionally shown off during
one of the Nintendo Direct live streams
this new Zelda Adventure will be the
first Nintendo published game to sell
for 70 bucks but the company believes
that the quality of the game will help
justify the 10 price increase Nintendo
added that not every one of its switch
games will cost 70 dollars and between
you and me don't tell anyone else about
this deal if you want to save some money
you should look into the switch game
vouchers where you get two games for a
hundred dollars tears of the kingdom is
eligible for this promotion so if you've
got your eye on another switch game as
well why not take advantage and save a
few bucks and maybe one of those games
you want to buy is Smash Bros an awesome
brawler for a hardcore multi-versus
Gamers to play When the Warner Bros
crossover fighter goes offline on June
5th but don't worry we're not planning a
funeral for multiverses yet this is just
the end of the open Beta period and the
game is expected to return for a full
launch in early 2024. this move comes as
a bit of a surprise as despite being
labeled as a beta many players didn't
expect the existing version of the game
to be taken offline let alone for what
could be six or more months in an
announcement video the co-founder for
player first games references the
feedback received during the nearly
year-long beta test as a major reason
for the decision with the quote content
Cadence of new characters maps and modes
cited as a specific Focus going forward
the game will still function in a
limited capacity via offline modes which
will include access to the lab training
areas as well as local offline matches
costumes characters and other Cosmetics
already purchased will remain available
in these offline modes in all progress
and purchases will carry over when the
full game launches who did you Main in
multiverses let me know in the comments
and also let me know what you expect to
see from the full game when it launches
next year it's kind of crazy we'll see
you tomorrow foreign